so how do you square the two  support fracking and  I don't I don't  I support fracking and I stand and I do  support fracking  that's  in his defense that's probably the best  answer he could possibly give because  there there is no explanation John  fetterman if he has been consistent on  anything in his career it's how much he  opposes fracking so even you can't  really blame this on the stroke or  anything like that this was a very  cynical political decision to lie by  fetterman's campaign and what's really  sad about this on the debate stage is it  would take a good politician a lot of  skill to be able to Jujitsu that  particular flip-flop but for someone  whose brain isn't working it's just not  possible